My cheek swab recommendation this week you put 2000 milligrams per day
for the vitamin C powder did you mean one scoop which is 2,200 milligrams
or the part that is vitamin C which is 1220 milligrams vitamin C per scoop
which would eat around two scoops per day.
Hold on a second, let me look up on what I did on the yours.
Well, precise. So your vitamin C powder 2000 milligrams per day. Oh, so what I meant to that is
is at least 2000 milligrams of vitamin C per day. So if there's only 1220 milligrams of vitamin C
per scoop, try to get two scoops that, sorry, that's where we two scoops are now.
I had HMET and biotoxid binder on this, it doesn't matter which one goal, a test of them because
it sounded like you may have one or another test of both and they both tested fine,
the carboxy tested fine too. So I would use up the carboxy first, the ET and the biotoxid
binder both tested the same. So whichever one you have, you could use.